Este es el primer supermercado ucraniano
que abre sus puertas en la recién
recuperada gerson ha pasado una semana
desde que las tropas ucranianas
volvieron a tener el control de la
estratégica ciudad el rublo y los
productos traídos por Rusia empiezan a
desaparecer yo no tenía rublos y nunca
compré productos rusos Hoy es el primer
día del lanzamiento de nuestro
supermercado favorito con productos
ucranianos por eso estoy aquí Quiero
comprar algo rico ni siquiera estamos
seguros de que comprar porque en
realidad necesitaríamos todos los
productos los precios Son muy buenos
pero no caben todos en nuestro carrito y
la cola es tan larga que llevamos dos
horas esperando aquí
pero no en todos los espacios será fácil
regresar a la normalidad Ucrania acusa a
Rusia de haber saqueado casi 15.000
artefactos del Museo de Arte de gerson
el Ministerio de cultura del país
contabiliza por lo menos un 80% de la
colección perdida pero esperan
recuperarlo todo cuanto antes bajo la
idea de que el arte es necesario para
sus ciudadanos en estos tiempos de
guerra
hemos liberado el teatro es gratis ahora
y comenzará a funcionar Tan pronto como
podamos Tan pronto como haya
electricidad realizaremos las primeras
actuaciones traeremos el elenco de kiev
el primer tren desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa también empezó a funcionar
este fin de semana una catedral ortodoxa
y otras zonas de área común fueron otros
de los espacios en donde los ucranianos
celebraron la liberación de la ciudad
por otro lado sin dar muchas
explicaciones el presidente ucraniano
aseguró haber encontrado sitios de
tortura en otra acusación para las
tropas rusas y su huella en la ciudad